Kaley Cuoco was a seasoned screen veteran
long before she started working as Penny on
The Big Bang Theory, but even she isn't immune
to the odd flub on the set every now and then.
Here's a look at some of the funniest goofs
from a very funny career.
In a ninth season episode of The Big Bang
Theory, Jim Parsons' Sheldon makes a video
for "Crazy Future Sheldon" and starts the
explanatory video for himself with some footage
of Penny who, in this outtake, is just way
too busy with her popcorn to care.
In another take, the camera stays on Sheldon,
who makes a wisecrack about Penny.
Penny and her popcorn, however, aren't having
it.
"If she offers you food, it's safe to take
You probably paid for it anyway."
As the script in this season three episode
was written, Cuoco's Penny reacts to a comment
from Simon Helberg's Howard by sarcastically
asking, "Are you high?"
At first, it's co-star Johnny Galecki who
flubs his follow-up line.
"Are you high?"
"You have a...English."
The director re-sets the scene and gives instructions
on where to start over, but Cuoco's still
concerned about Galecki.
"Are you high?"
Still, that's not the end.
"My point is…"
"High!"
The Big Bang Theory characters hold the Star
Trek franchise in high esteem throughout the
series.
One would think that all of that Star Trek
stuff constantly on the set would have forced
its way into Kaley Cuoco's brain.
But that's clearly not the case, at least
when she's supposed to be giving Spock's famous
Vulcan salute.
"I am Spock…Did I do it wrong?...I did?!
I've been doing it...Oh, this way."
In this blooper, Kaley Cuoco stumbles over
a word she probably has to say more than any
other in the line of duty: "Leonard," the
name of her character's neighbor, then boyfriend,
then husband.
"Leonar...Leonar.."
"Leonard."
"Balls!"
Cuoco's blooper then grows infectious, as
co-star Jim Parsons can't get through the
next part of the scene without fudging his
own dialogue.
"...surprisingly, uh, gripping...oh no…"
"Balls.
The key word is balls."
"Balls!"
In the early seasons of The Big Bang Theory,
Penny makes ends meet waitressing at the Cheesecake
Factory while pursuing her dream of being
an actress.
To save money, she subsequently exploits her
proximity to the guys by helping herself to
their food as well as their wifi.
In this fifth season episode, Penny casually
enters the guys' apartment to get the new
wifi password, but doesn't seem to understand
what one actually does with wifi.
"Okay, if you can't get me to stop eating
your food, what makes you think you can stop
me from eating your wifi?"
The ABC sitcom 8 Simple Rules for Dating My
Teenager Daughter was Kaley Cuoco's first
major role on a successful show.
She portrayed the slightly rebellious and
independent daughter of beloved TV icon John
Ritter.
The kid versus adult struggle at the center
of the show becomes comically real in this
blooper from the first season.
"Stop imitating me!"
"No!
I was-"
"Stop it!"
Yes, you can rib Kaley Cuoco on a sitcom set,
but she can give as good as she gets, even
to a legend like John Ritter!
On the set of 8 Simple Rules, Cuoco can't
really start her scene until Ritter walks
onto the stage and boy is she impatient.
"Ritter!
Action!"